We are aware of this station eight recorded in Sydney on Tuesday the twenty ninth of July nine hundred ninety seven
and great talking to fate. Where up to. Yes we are indeed. So after the very liked night at the club.
They told us that they wanted a couple of us to go out
and fitted three children the orphans of the participants who fought. And so they called for us picked us up.
And the first place. We stopped it was a cemetery. And not very far from the symmetry was. And these children were all.
Five six year olds and they may have mentioned this before but in case I didn't.
I'll just say that they took us to the symmetry of the children's fathers
and told us how the Germans had cut their heads off and put their heads sticks.
And asked to go on identify their husbands.
And so they brought very close to all the children who were left with our parents where they have to file for us
and some of the mothers were came along and created us. I mean to pick up they too old to leave the children.
And so we. Some time. You know all the children. With little bug. Waiting for us so we left we went to our pottery.
And I'd always heard about pottery. And this was a place where people who were really known as peasants lived.
They lived from the land and it was a very hard existence of course for them. But they had they killed. Hugh.
And other Africans for food where they put their bread in so on. And that was about one hundred from.
The first place which caught out and then told us or not been more
but it was a very long long tricked over mountains and valleys and finally we got told us.
How they were virtually untouched by the war because they were cut off from the cities. And.
But were certainly very aware of. There in photographs and lift presents and i gave me a present.
A sample of their pottery four beautiful cups and saucers and four very small four black coffee coffee a beautiful.
Cocoa jug. It was. Well. And that was given to me. OPEC up nicely. There were other pieces in it as well. Anyhow.
We had a very said it had been converted actually into a co-operative. And all of the fire this.
Pool in the vegetables and fruit and I said I found that far more profitable than taking it to the markets in town.
There was a lot of battering. So then we left and went to a government co-operative and that was a huge huge.
Was the type of. A very very long table. And that I had made it.
Kerry using the wonderful capsicums beautiful lot of Chile caps to my heart. Cucumber.
And basically a vegetarian curry but huge huge bowls of hurt.
Well put on the table brought in steaming coffee and huge beholds of potato.
Boiled potatoes he said went with Terry and. We all sat down with the leaders of the co-op.
And over here hanging answers of. Chile.
They were dry the whole ceiling looked radiant green with these beautiful bunches of chilies and capsicum.
Hanging the country for capsicums like Hungary Hungary and.
We had a wonderful meal there and they brought in a bazooka.
I say we sang with them we staying together we did a dance for them.
It was just wonderful wonderful beautiful feeling of. Genuine comradeship.
And as we really presented us once again there were many persons maybe prisons but in particular the bars.
Blair House which had been hand. Of the most beautiful creams.
And it was a traditional traditional as you know and they have not blackouts and that have you brought it sleeve for
and. Just beautiful and they gave I was with an Australian free. And she was very fear.
So they gave her the blouse with a pink and green tree and they gave me with the red and orange tree was a lovely.
Just lovely.
Well by then you know I could have gone on for hours on end we went through the fire and the women were very.
Who and welcoming and they touched us they just wanted to touch us.
We touched him and that was the exchange you know because the language was a great barrier.
Although we had interpreters with language was a barrier with because of which are so many people
and then we went back to the city. And then the next day they said to me. Well.
We had a wonderful leader and his name was Judy Dimitroff. Well I had read a lot about your duty mantra. And he was.
Wilfred Burchett the Australian journalist had a bit to do with him and was a great admirer of Demetra. Well.
Dimeter of course was a Communist Party you know what he did was lift the people out of the terrible poverty they were
in. Any had asked me if I would like to go and see the house he lived in a city.
So we went off to see his house and it was. And what people try of had I mean Sion this because I want to remember.
One of his great achievements was to banish the common bowl.
And they're on the little table in his little eating room cottage the with so many bells
and one bowl in the center saying that for us.
How many if you went to bag area of the original delegation that for very small. Yes.
So then we were put on the train for great celebrations again and the best local band was there to.
Play us on the train.
And one of things that interested me
and consoled me somewhat that I was we traveled all the way from Bulgaria changing trains at different stations going
right on to Paris. I noticed in the Eastern Bloc. I had three.
Compartment three classes of travel
and I thought oh mighty I thought it was all about banishing the class system you know.
And so there were three Army offices in the beautiful plush first US and then we were also in first class
but not quite as plush and then the hearse.
I suppose what we did I would call economy where business people appeared to be travelling.
You know they had briefcases and out in the corridor packed packed the corridors where the poor people.
And they would you're sitting on top of their bags of wheat or whatever it was sitting on the. Blankets.
Everyone had a huge round loaf of bread tacked under their arms which away from you and I looked desperately.
Not hungry but had put had put. So I thought well you know I'm not of you sure about this. Classless society.
So we went back through the his beautiful country. Beautiful country. Went to Paris.
I stayed on in Paris for a little while. Mainly because I couldn't pay myself away from it.
Just booking the streets just loving it. And finally I got on the train who went to Cali and after. Those two.
And then I went up to London. And joined up with the rest of the delegation in London.
And they were all living in cheap dives because money was running out of paper you know why for. Nearly six months.
And I was cheap if I had nothing else I wanted. Because winter was coming on. And finally I put myself into it.
In Bloomsbury. It was such a thought nothing flashy of course but you know. Nineteen fifty one.
It was and sure you still had to walk in the passage way to the Danny and so forth
but that was luxury compared with what my other friends were living in.
And some were social some of had flights and as many as seven
and I had all opted just to wait until a boat was to leave you. So you know it wasn't leaving until December.
Midwinter. Anyhow I was in this lovely comfortable in Bloomsbury.
And once again I made with my engineering friend from Whole been told you about.
The cold call it caught who had been coming over to London.
And his wife Beth had come to join him she'd gone off somewhere I think she went to Moscow before she went on to London.
And there was a journalist acquaintance of his by the name of Mark. And I met the three of them. And they said to me.
Listen if I did. We're going to buy a car. And you. In a day or two we're going up to Bedford to get it.
And these cars were just on the market. British javelin and they pooled the money they had could get.
And now having gone through the east we're going through that waste.
If you throw in for food and petrol and pay here and accommodation when we left.
Accommodation will come with us so that won't happen got the car like came back and we went to the markets.
To buy food in London or so cheap leaving cheap like thousands of keepers and sardines all that stuff
and that was just what we wanted and New Zealand care and better.
So we went to the markets and we filled the boxes boat a Primus
and methylated kerosene all those things you need to get the promise caring for. And then I said well we were.
Under the Stars.
And sure enough so that I had been to a disposal shop I don't know who you're too young to remember the disposal shops
but after the war we had big disposal shops that were selling for stuff.
And people voted because you know particularly people who were building houses because they came over the hill to see
so and they had both a parachute number one. They would ready.
We all had sleeping bags and various pieces of canvas and what if you and I said they have it.
So we got into this brand new javelin and we set our. It was so beautiful I will never forget it.
I had to pinch myself to tell me it was true. First stop was. Paris.
And we were going to that occasionally we'd have a me an evening meal a cheap evening meal while best French was very
good. So we went looking for an evening meal and we went over a structure which was on the list.
And it had a very limited menu. And it had. Made which was cooked in WA. And Rice wasn't anything else.
So we all got stuck into this and eating meat you know it was still rationed in England and so on. Great luxury.
So we got stuck into this rice and meat. And we paid. And we left.
Well this business of tipping where it is in Australia is relatively new to people of my age.
Because there was a time when you wouldn't dream of tipping only that people who were into the Australian
and princes and Ramallah. Believed in tipping. And I have to say that Hanson I agreed. We're never going to tip again.
And we didn't last night. So of course we didn't. And we saw Paris. I wanted to live. And we it was like.
I thought it was the most beautiful city on it.
So then we said we're getting hungry so let's go back to our restaurant again and we are sure that wouldn't serve us.
Now that's it. And this is where our.
No that's not no I did it was a vote even though she said I would give you a little bit will give you a little bit
about an inch. But.
So we had to go and buy food into the markets and bought food on the players and got the promise it had started.
Cooking the potato is when the cops and I was making the baby it's you know put it. You put them.
Parachute proof and we idea was to lie on some rocks then hop in your sleeping bag and you're right.
The cops should not torture. And this is now you can stay here. This is a public park it can't come.
So we said we're moving hard Could we stay for that night and. They looked at us and. We told them we're not English.
We were not American but Australian
and they were rather fascinated with this for us trillions camping in whatever asked cities.
You know you can stay there.
No Ari but go early in the morning when we're all of us left early in the morning because it was said.
Lovely to see the place in the early hours.
So we've potatoes at night and tin of herrings or whatever it was the next morning we pushed off
but we muster stayed I think about leaving a week just seeing as much as we could and then we drove down from there.
We went through he says to me. And over to Austria again.
And we just stayed one night camping in the hand and went on to Salzburg.
And we were sitting up camp on the outskirts of selves.
You know my job was always make that we just put the Big Gram covering down
and then we'd all just lie on it because it prevented the cull come from coming through hopping to us splitting the
eggs and we would just have to get it to behave. When the cops came. And I said.
And but you haven't wasn't too bad they are now on television. And they said Now you come. This is just not so nice it.
Will go very very early in the morning or I said but don't think you know it's been very quiet. Good night.
Then we had a life with a radio with no use and we'd sleep in a sleeping bag.
Just for you to for it to rain while we threw the Macintosh over also.
So we stayed in cells but and didn't like it for some reason or other.
You know there was still a strong smell of the Nazis. And of course a were very.
Very much in lanes to sell spur that's why this is in the area of Hitler's beginnings.
So we didn't stay awfully long there was summer another place and feeling about it all.
I must say it was had to leave the beauty of it but then we said we'll go over the last climb Gloucester up
and go right over and come down. And we did just.
So we set off from the roof to leave in the morning and we took all the bedding we had with us in the car.
Because the car didn't have heat. And. It was practically a food. Right up to the very peak you were in the next day.
Well when we reached the peak of the Alps. We couldn't get half for Tarika at all.
We just had to look out and there were many. Snow. Coverage snow clearing the roads.
So we had to take it slowly of course. And we said to the workman. Cafes.
And they said no you don't have to go to the bottom of the helps.
And there is a resupply and we think you can get some nice hot soup there.
So all the while he was there I think for the hot soup and family were in Iraq.
And there was a little cafe right at the gate on the border and when she said can you have soup pancakes we suggest.
There were fire pancakes filled with potato. Why do you do it is that it was the last crumb of this.
I mean if we were under if now coffee I'm not heard of heard of milk cows there
and they could have it's much milk with its would like to drink.
We have just got stuck in the heat in the milk and that was a. So we're at the bottom of the mountain.
So we were pleased to cross into Italy. And. It was a little more. Because it had. I'm sorry.
I've just got to come back in case I forget this.
I want to say that when we lift France and we were traveling through western Germany. We spent some time in Western.
And color. We went and saw the destruction to the cathedral which was a magnificent thing.
But I recall going to the group still works. Which were in either cologne and I'll have to check that out.
And we went as the workers were finished the shift was finishing for the day this was in the month of early November.
And the cold had started very much. And the workers were coming out from the the works. Dragging the souls of the.
And the hymn of their trousers. Poverty stricken. Looking so desperately beaten beaten. And.
We stopped outside to stop a car outside of the gate. One man was on. Said to him.
Do you work here now and he said yes and this is the crop who are still works. Do they pay you well. Is that good.
It's very bad and I had some cigarettes in his pocket. Put a cigarette in his math and offered it to the. Work.
And the work. Reluctantly to could but graceful. You know cigarettes a cigarette would have been quite a luxury quite.
And it was going through. And then we went to.
And going to Heidelberg was quite an experience because it still somehow or other retained a lot of its beauty.
It didn't seem to me to be as devastated as the other city.
It could well have been but the surroundings were very very beautiful very beautiful.
And then we said well we must go through the Black Forest always has the Black Forest
and I guess that was the only uncomfortable night we had on the whole trip. We didn't realise it would be so cold.
We found. Hunters hat with the hunters.
And we were able to make a fire but that was totally inadequate to keep ourselves.
We left very early the next morning from their travel and then we went to the. Edge of the rock for quite some time.
I remember looking and seeing the lower. She looked. And then of course who went over to Austria.
But I just wanted to remember having gone to the cripple.
They were working already in valley and you might remember that it was croup who made the poisonous gas gas.
So we arrived in Italy and it was an entirely different atmosphere. I've already seen an awful lot of Italy growing up.
And I knew it pretty well and I was sort of a Scot in the atlas on this trip.
So the first place we went to were general. And I knew the mayor had met the mayor of China where you see.
So it was nice. He took us into the dock and told us what they were doing and then he said.
The North was always known to be the late as you know initially at that time and for many years after he took us.
And then he said at the end of the day after giving us a while under full meal of spaghetti bowl
and he says would you like to come to a Marxist class tonight and we will suggest we'll have to.
I'll send you an interpreter. And she will bring you. So the interpreter and her name was franca. A medical student.
Who carried her to and from university. So that the letter would know where. And her English was perfect.
So we had Franco who took us to the Marxist class
and I have wondered what it would be like it was you know huge hole they were hanging from the rafters
and that it's just. Loaded Frank has sat next to be madly interpretating get it to print. And I thought. This is life.
Thank God hope for the future late throw my happen out of.
And here with the telly and partisans back in their marxist classes again.